>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, D.C.
>> Sharon Horowitz: Good afternoon.
Welcome to the African and
Middle Eastern Reading Room.
On behalf of the Hebraic
Section, let me thank you all
for coming to today's program.
My name is Sharon Horowitz.
I am a reference librarian
in the Hebraic Section.
Customarily, our Division Chief,
Mary Jane Deeb greets you all,
our esteemed program attendees, and
today she had a schedule conflict
for this hour, so I was asked to
convey her warm welcome to you all.
The Hebraic Section marks its
beginning in 1912 with the receipt
of 10,000 Hebrew books
and pamphlets,
whose purchase was
made possible by a gift
from New York philanthropist,
Jacob Shiff.
From those humble beginnings,
our collections have grown
to around 250,000 items.
In Hebrew, Yiddish,
Latin, Judeo-Persian
and other Hebraic script languages.
The Hebraic Section also includes
an important selection of books
in [foreign words spoken],
the languages of Ethiopia,
past and present.
Our section's holdings
are particularly strong
in the subject areas of
Bible and Rabbinics, liturgy
and Hebrew language, and
response and Jewish history.
Two of our missions in this division
are to publicize our collections,
and to bring people
into the library.
One way we accomplish this second
goal is by holding lectures
and having programs such as the
one we are hosting here today.
And now, a word about
our presenters.
In 2016, Ellen Cassedy won a
PEN/Heim Translation Grant,
the first ever awarded
to a Yiddish project.
In 2015 and 16, she was
a Translation Fellow
at the Yiddish Book Center
in Amhurst, Massachusetts.
Her translations have
appeared in numerous journals.
She is the author of We Are Here,
Memories of the Lithuanian
Holocaust,
which won several national awards.
Yermiyahu Ahron Talb is the
author of five books of poetry,
including most recently The
Education of a Daffodil.
He was honored by the Museum
of Jewish Heritage as one
of New York's best emerging artists,
and his short stories have appeared
in Jewishfiction.net, Jewish
Literary Journal, Jewrotica,
and Second Hand Stories podcast.
He is also a colleague of ours
here at the Library of Congress.
One item of business
before we begin.
This event is being video taped
for subsequent broadcasting.
There will be a formal question and
answer period after the lecture,
at which the audience is encouraged
to ask questions and offer comments.
Please be advised that your
voice and image may be recorded
and later broadcast
as part of this event.
By participating in the Q&A
period, you are consenting
to the Library's possible
reproduction
and transmission of your remarks.
And now, please join me in
welcoming Mr. Yermiyahu Ahron Talb,
and Miss Ellen Cassedy.
[ Applause ]
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb: Okay.
So, [foreign word spoken]
everyone, welcome, welcome.
Thank you, Sharon, for
that warm introduction.
Thank you all for coming
during your lunch hour today.
We would like to thank Sharon
Horowitz and Dr. Ann Brenner,
of the Hebraic Section for
organizing this program.
Dr. Mary Jane Deeb,
Chief of the African
and Middle Eastern
Division, for her support.
We also want to thank
our wonderful publishers,
Robert Mandel of Mandel Vilar Press,
and Meryl Lefler [assumed
spelling] of Dryad Press.
We also honor the work of
the talented translators
of Yiddish literature
today, and generations past,
who have made this
great literature known
to an English language readership.
In particular, we acknowledge
the pioneering work of Bridges,
a Journal for Jewish
Feminists, and our friends,
for serving as a publication venue
for the translation of the work
of Yiddish women writers.
In some ways, our work builds on
theirs, was made possible by theirs.
Today is a great pleasure to
share with you the life and work
of Blume Lempel, a writer who
deserves to be much better known
by English language readers.
The two of us have spent more
than 10 years, and many weekends
around Ellen's dining room
table, immersed in the life
and work of this unique writer.
And now, with the publication
of our translated collection
of her short stories, we are
glad to have the opportunity
to share our findings with you.
Today, we will take you on a kind
of mystery tour, to answer questions
like these: where did
this writer come from?
Who was she?
What set her on her unusual path?
What kept her going
through her long career?
Why did she write in Yiddish?
And what does she have to
offer a contemporary audience
like ourselves?
Blume Lempel was a unique
writer, one of a kind,
but she was part of
a larger picture.
So as we look at Blume
Lempel, we'll also be exploring
that larger context of what it
was to be a writer in Yiddish
in the second half
of the 20th Century
in the United States,
and as a woman.
But first, a word about how
we stumbled into this project,
and then we'll get into
Blume Lempel's story.
>> Ellen Cassedy: Years ago,
I began studying Yiddish
as a memorial to my mother.
My mother was Jewish,
unlike my father,
and had grown up around Yiddish.
She didn't actually speak Yiddish,
but she would sprinkle a word here,
and a word there, into her
conversation sort of like a spice.
So in the kitchen,
she might say "hand me
that shissle [phonetic spelling]"
Does anyone know what that means?
No? Bowl. Or she'd stand at the
window on a rainy day and say,
"Amabel [phonetic spelling]"
which meant "a flood."
On the phone, the woman's [Yiddish
spoken], a witch [laughter].
So I hope that by studying Yiddish,
I would strengthen my connection
to my cultural legacy, and really
find a home within Jewish culture,
and that has turned out to be true.
Yiddish is very precious to me,
for its outsider point of view,
its humor, its standing up
for the little guy, its irony,
and its honoring of the everyday.
So early on in my study of Yiddish,
I was living in Philadelphia,
and I told my teacher, who
was himself a translator,
that I wanted to try
my hand at translation.
At that time, I had about two months
of Yiddish study under my belt,
I thought, "I'm ready for this."
And he went straight
to his book shelf,
and he pulled out this
little gray volume.
He opened it up, and he told me this
was by a writer named Blume Lempel,
and he showed me how
it was inscribed
to him personally by the author.
Then I met Ahron in a
Yiddish reading group.
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb: I grew
up in an Orthodox Shiva family
surrounded by Jewish languages,
including Yiddish, and I formally
studied Yiddish as an adult.
I've been involved in Yiddish
culture since the early 1990s.
A long time now.
As a reader, writer, translator and
activist, Yiddish is for me a place
of primal connection, and
cultural imagining and possibility.
>> Ellen Cassedy: So we opened up
this little gray volume and began
to read, and we were, frankly, blown
away by its truly unique writing.
Experimental, taboo-defying,
fearless, lyrical.
And there were surprises
at every turn.
In on every page, in
virtually every paragraph,
we had never seen any writer
like this in any language.
At the time, years ago, we knew
almost nothing about Blume Lempel,
beyond the fact that she'd been
born in 1907, in Khorostkov,
a little town in what
was then Galicia,
part of the Austro-Hungarian Empire,
later it became part of Poland,
now it is in Ukraine, in what she
described as a whitewashed room
by the banks of a river
that had no name.
And we wondered who was this
woman who came out of this place,
who wrote with such feeling
and with so many exact details
about a very wide range of settings,
from the old world to the new,
pre-war Paris, Cosmopolitan Paris,
New York, California, Yosemite Park.
How did somebody like her emerged
from a little whitewashed room
to become such a groundbreaking
writer?
So we went hunting, and we
tracked down Blume Lempel's heirs,
her relatives, and her former
colleagues, and found boxes
of her personal papers
stored in an attic.
We came here to the
Library of Congress.
We went to the Jewish Research
Institute called YIVO, in New York.
And a picture began to emerge.
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb: We
learned that Blume's father,
Abraham Pfeffer, was a butcher, and
that her mother, Pesha, read novels,
subscribed to a newspaper from
the nearby city of Lvov, Lvov,
and was considered
cultured by the townspeople.
Blume's older brother
received a formal education,
but her own schooling was sporadic.
For a few years, she attended
a religious school for girls,
and a Hebrew Folk School, and at
times, a tutor came to the house.
As she later recalled in an
interview with the Yiddish scholar,
Itzel Gottesman, "My father
believed that all a girl needed
to know was how to cook a pot of
food, sew a patch, and milk a cow."
In Poland, she remembered,
"I didn't write at all.
I only dreamed of writing."
As she dreamed, she
stored up observations
that would later appear in her work.
All her life, her childhood
self remained accessible
to her as, "The girl who was.
The girl whose tides ebb and flow
on my sandy shores, to this day."
>> Ellen Cassedy: So, for a time,
Blume Lempel's childhood
world seemed safe and secure.
As the narrator in one story says,
"Enclosed within my father's words
and my mother's tears, the world
came to me as a completed picture,
and I accepted its
pre-ordained colors and nuances
as part of the natural order.
Just as the sun rose every
morning behind our barn,
and set every evening
behind the tree
that my father pointed
out with his finger.
So, I stayed within the picture
frame, walking in the light,
avoiding the shadows, never
straying beyond the borders."
And this is from a story called
Even the Heavens Tell Lies,
[Yiddish words spoken].
Now, would you like
to hear it in Yiddish?
A little paragraph.
And for those that don't know
Yiddish, remember the words
of Franz Kafka, who said, "Ladies
and gentlemen, don't be afraid
of Yiddish, you'll understand
more than you thought you would."
So here is that paragraph,
in Yiddish.
[ Yiddish Spoken ]
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb: When
Blume was 12, that comforting sense
of order began to crumble.
Her mother died, and when her
father remarried, Blume was pressed
into service as a housekeeper
and nursemaid
for the new couple,
and their young child.
Her brother, Yisroel, eight
years older, had become involved
in militant communist activity.
He was caught and imprisoned, then
escaped, and went into hiding.
Yisroel fled to France,
and in 1929, at age 22,
Blume too left Khorostkov.
She was intending to become
a pioneer in Palestine,
but on the way, she stopped
off in Paris to visit Yisroel,
who settled in the Jewish immigrant
neighborhood of Belleville.
Captivated by the city of light,
Blume abandoned her pioneer plans.
She found a job in a factory, where
she met her husband Lemel Lempel.
They started a family.
Her dream of becoming a
writer began to take shape.
She began writing poems, and
meeting other Yiddish writers.
During the 10 years
Blume lived in Paris,
she fell in love with the city.
It became the setting for some
of her most important work,
including a novel set
in the years before
and during World War II,
and many short stories.
>> Ellen Cassedy: So,
just before World War II,
the family was extremely fortunate
to be able to flee to New York,
and here they are, a couple of years
after the war, the whole family.
Those two children.
And in America, Blume reached
out to the New York Jewish,
Yiddish literary scene, especially
the newspaper Morgen Freiheit,
and she began to publish a
serialized novel, and short stories.
But then, the news from Europe
began to trickle in, and she learned
that back in her hometown, her
father's wife, and their young son,
had been seized and
killed by the Nazis,
and that her father had
then burned down the house
and hanged himself on
a tree in their yard.
She also learned that on the
day before liberation of France,
her brother, who had joined the
resistance, was captured and shot,
leaving behind his
wife and two sons.
As she later said, she was
catapulted into a deep despair.
The past was a graveyard,
the future without meaning.
I sat paralyzed within
a self-imposed prison.
The years went by.
Many desolate, fruitless years.
She began to burn her work.
But then came a turning point.
She had two friends who were
Yiddish writers, and they suggested
that she dedicate herself to writing
about the terrible destruction
that was consuming her.
And that idea, she said,
opened a psychological door.
She wrote, "I felt I must speak for
those who could no longer speak.
Feel for those who
could no longer feel.
Immerse myself in their unlived
lives, their sorrows, their joys,
their struggle and their death."
So she had found her calling, which
was to express the experience of,
as she put it, "The survivors.
The broken people who attempt after
the war to establish a new link
to life, and who through
it all remain broken."
And this was her own experience.
An experience of displacement
and flight, and adaptation,
and a special burden of remembering,
retribution, guilt and grief.
And in an approach that
was uniquely her own,
she often approached her subject
not head-on, but through a variety
of subtle literary strategies,
in which the great cataclysm
of the 20th Century is
never far from the surface,
but it's hovering just out of sight,
appearing in powerful
glimpses, powerful flashes.
Many of her stories are
jagged and disjointed.
They don't move smoothly from
point A to point B. Instead,
sometimes within one
single sentence,
you'll find Lempel's imagination
moving back and forth between dream
and reality, past and
present, old world, and new.
And Ahron and I think that this
jaggedness is a carefully considered
literary choice, one that is
unusual among Jewish writers.
We think it's a conscious
reflection of the disruptions
in the author's life, and
the lives of her characters.
A brilliant, ingenious
way to convey the restless
and unsettled existence
that she knew so well.
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb:
So here is an example.
In the story called The
Little Red Umbrella,
a middle-aged woman named Janet,
in New York City, gets a phone call
from a poet she met
at a Hanukah party.
He invites her out on a date.
He is one of a series of dates
she's had over the years.
Most of them not that great.
Including, as she tells
us, a washed-up actor,
a sock manufacturer, a card-player,
a man who had left his wife
and child to travel around
the world in disguise."
So it doesn't look good.
But this is a woman who
doesn't give up hope.
And so listen to how,
within a single paragraph,
Lempel catapults us out of Janet's
studio apartment, into the cosmos.
The rendezvous with the poet came
like a jolt from the very heart
of life, awakening the butterflies
from their lethargic dozing.
Light, silk wings hovered
in the air.
The studio apartment, which a moment
before had been cold and dark,
brightened with an ethereal light.
The walls began to sing again.
There's still life at close
to 50, she said to the fly
that was spending the
winter in her house.
Fantastic patterns streamed through
the cracks in the Venetian blinds.
Lost ships swarmed to her mountain,
bringing regards from distant lands.
Magic keys to locked doors.
Janet followed a voice
through the dark corridors.
She opens one of the
doors, and inside,
a purple light filled the room.
On a bed of sky-blue silk, the Greek
was lounging with a high-borne lady.
Janet swims without moving
over still water, not forward,
but backward in time,
from today to yesterday.
The shift takes her
to the middle ages,
to another world, on
another continent.
She continues on to the land of
Socrates, Plato, and Aristotle.
Then, to the promised
land of milk and honey.
Under an outspread
fig tree, Adam dozes.
She approaches him.
Then, the telephone rings, and Janet
goes to the closet, gets dressed,
puts on her makeup and steps out
into the streets of Manhattan,
on her way to the date
with the poet.
The story goes on from
there, and once again,
the Holocaust makes an
appearance in an unexpected way.
Now, the erotic imaginings
of a middle-aged woman are not
standard fare in any literature,
and Lempel's approach to spooling
out this character's fantasies
so freely is quite unusual.
So, how did she summon the
courage to write this way?
>> Ellen Cassedy: Perhaps the most
important factor was that by 1970,
she had won the support of
Abraham Sutzkever, who was renowned
through the world of Yiddish letters
as a poet, as a cultural hero
who had rescued treasured Jewish
texts in the Vilna ghetto,
and as the editor of the leading
Yiddish literary journal called Di
goldene keyt, which was
published in Tel Aviv.
Sutzkever's right-hand man
was Alexander Spiegel-Vaught,
and here is what the
Di goldene keyt,
which means the golden
chain look like,
and the golden chain means
the golden chain of Yiddish
or Jewish literature that
is passed on from one writer
to the next down through the ages.
So after receiving her
first letter of acceptance
from Di goldene keyt,
Lempel recalled this.
"I still remember how surprised
I was at the warm answer.
I remember even that it was a cold,
cloudy winter day, but for me,
spring gardens burst into
the most beautiful bloom.
The energy that I'd conserved in my
youth came out from under my apron."
Sutzkever and Lempel
corresponded for 20 years,
and here we see an
early letter from him,
complete with a rather charming
drawing, a portrait, self-portrait,
signed, "All the best,
with love, Sutzkever."
And while another editor might
have tried to reign her in,
to smooth out her rough edges,
or tame her bold choices,
what was critically
important about this editor,
Abraham Sutzkever,
was that he never did.
Instead, he deeply
affirmed her individuality.
He wrote, "You have your own
words, your own observations,
your own madness, which you
scoop out from within yourself
like shovelfuls of hot coals.
Your talent is not an ordinary one.
Of that I am sure."
So Sutzkever allowed
Lempel free reign
to pursue her unique
narrative strategies, and this,
like the earlier intervention of
Lempel's few Yiddish writer friends,
was a key factor in the development
of her singular contribution
to Yiddish literature.
Lempel wrote back to Sutzkever,
"I write not for my
readers, but for myself.
I write for the dybbuk
that is seeking a transformation
through me."
Now in Jewish folk culture, a
dybbuk is the soul of a dead person
that takes up residence inside
a living individual and strives
for expression through that
person, and Sutzkever wrote back,
"for that dibbick you must write.
You must write for
yourself, and for me,
and for that chosen writer whom
every true talent brings into being
through the magnetic
power of the work itself.
Now, I think this is a
very interesting concept,
that the writer kind of creates
an ideal reader inside his
or her own head, and that reader is
the one that the writer writes for.
"Your prose," Sutzkever said, "is
in essence poetic, and therefore,
it must be pure and
careful, like pure poetry.
Every drop is as important
as the rushing current.
Sincerely, and with
much belief in you."
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb:
Another important sustaining force
was the poet, Malka Heifetz Tussman,
and here we see a photo
of her with her husband,
both in bathing suits, no less.
And here is a letter, here is a
letter from her, in which she talks
about the complex and very personal
literary home that Lempel had built.
She writes, "Blume, Blume, why do
you think your poems would shock me?
Not so. Good poems, Blume.
You dive into the self,
and behold, a sbibh."
Here is Blume, and you can see
even the letter itself is written
as a poem.
In Yiddish, the word sbibh means
"environment" or "atmosphere."
But it can also note
fellowship and connection.
It is a place where one belongs.
A home. The sbibh that Blume
Lempel constructed for herself,
the sustaining literary home,
was part privacy and solitude,
part support and community.
As writers ourselves, we are
fascinated by Blume's sbibh,
and how richly rewarding
it clearly was for her.
In Heifetz Tussman's words,
"Blume is her own sbibh."
And that is an important part
of the truth, but only one part.
The support of other
writers was also a key part
of what sustained her.
Lempel's work became known
in the Yiddish world.
As we were able to see in the
holdings here at the Library
of Congress, it was published in a
great variety of Yiddish journals,
in Tel Aviv, New York,
Los Angeles, Melbourne,
Australia, Paris, and South Africa.
She won several literary prizes,
including the EKUF
[phonetic spelling] prize,
the I.J. Seigel Prize, awarded
by the Jewish Public Library
in Montreal, and the Haim
Shetovk [assumed spelling] Prize.
>> Ellen Cassedy: In
1979, she began preparing
for her first short story
collection to publish it,
and for editorial help, she turned
to this Tel Aviv poet named
Denham Heller [phonetic spelling]
and he urged her to include
even her most daring stories,
ones that had been rejected
by literary magazines,
including Oedipus in Brooklyn,
the story that Sutzkever
himself has turned down.
And the result was this book, A
Moment Fun Ams, "a moment of truth,"
the volume that my teacher
put in my hand 10 years later,
and once the book was published,
praise began to pour in.
Praise that recognized that hers was
a unique voice, a talent distinct
from others in the
Yiddish literary world.
The writer, the celebrated
Yiddish writer, Chaim Grade,
wrote to her how sad it was that
her talent had flowered so late,
when there were so few readers who
could read her work in the original,
but he said maybe this was
inevitable, because she belonged
so much to her own
time, and no other time.
So listen to what he says.
"It is enough to make one weep
that you appeared in our literature
at a time when so few
good readers remained,
but perhaps it could
not have been otherwise.
Perhaps your magical, sweet,
lyrical tone could not have come
into being any earlier
than our autumn years.
You are a modern writer in
the most beautiful sense.
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb: Lempel
also attracted the attention
of the Montreal writer, Java
Rosenfarb [phonetic spelling],
who introduced herself
to Lempel in a letter.
"I've been reading your work
in Di goldene keyt," she wrote.
"I feel very close to your
way of writing, to your style.
Who are you?"
The two women exchanged warm
and frequent letters until 1990,
critiquing each other's work,
revealing their struggles
with writing and publishing, sharing
their views of other writers,
some of which are not so positive,
and offering news about
their families.
Rosenfarb wrote, "I
admire the beauty
and austerity of your language.
You are so economical, careful
not to waste a single word."
We agree. As translators, we found
her prose so poetic and so rich
that we had to work very hard
to capture her unique melody,
one that we found to be denser, more
idiosyncratic, more well...unhinged,
than that of other women
or men writing in Yiddish.
That one...
>> Ellen Cassedy: Perfect, perfect.
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb: Lempel's
second collection came out in 1986,
and was called "Balade fun a
kholem," ballad of a dream.
Like her first book, it
contains an extraordinary range
of subject matter.
In her stories, we meet
women and girls of all ages.
A lonely little girl who is too
poor to own a doll, so she draws one
with her finger on
a misty windowpane.
A madwoman dancing
in the marketplace.
A mother and son living
in the forest
with the squirrels to
hide from the Nazis.
A woman lying on her back on a
table, in an abortion clinic.
A woman who occupies herself
with extravagant daydreams,
as she and her husband drive
to Florida for the winter.
An anti-Nazi spy in Paris, disguised
behind a mask of glamorous makeup.
A deeply religious African
American woman living in Brooklyn.
A woman named Pakasandra [phonetic
spelling], who tells a lie
to save her son's life, and
then is obsessed with the fear
that God will punish her for the
sin of bearing false witness.
In response to the second volume,
Yunya Fein [phonetic spelling],
a Yiddish writer, an artist who
lived in New York, wrote to Lempel.
And we think this is a really
nice synthesis of her writing.
Yunya wrote, "Throughout
your stories, time undulates.
Not measured or divided into
past, present and future.
As long as we are alive, we carry
all times within us simultaneously.
And who knows for sure what
is fact and what is dream?
And who can say with certainty how
much arrival there is in going away?
And how much going away in arriving?
These and many other
questions are woven
in a natural way into your work."
For example, the aforementioned
Pakasandra,
the woman who told a lie, lives
with the images of Biblical figures
in her mind, all day, every day.
Here is a brief excerpt.
"All day, while her mind
was busy with this and that,
the images were in motion.
She saw Abraham's caravan
on the edge of the desert,
and the matriarch, Sarah, encircled
by a retinue of maidservants.
And wrapped in white linen, riding
side saddle on a small donkey.
Pakasandra couldn't see her face,
but sensed her royal bearing.
And with the utmost respect, she
chose not to peel away the swaths
of fabric protecting her privacy.
The images populated Pakasandra's
world, which she tended
in a special chamber of her being.
Minute as a pinhead,
and yet, infinite."
>> Ellen Cassedy: And now, a word,
for what you've been waiting for,
about the title story,
Oedipus in Brooklyn.
What is this?
This was a story that Sutzkever
considered too shocking
to publish and maybe he was right.
You can be the judge.
But we find that in Lempel's hands,
the account of a contemporary
woman involved
in a transgressive relationship
with her son is not sensational,
not tawdry, and not
played for laughs.
Step by step, Lempel leads us
into the heart of darkness.
She tells about the car
accident that kills the father
and blinds the son, of the growing
closeness of mother and son,
and of their increasing isolation.
And finally, the two of them leave
the familiar streets of Brooklyn,
and move to Florida, which becomes
a perfect backdrop of horror
for the tragedy that
is beginning to unfold.
Here is her description of Florida.
"A blinding haze hung in
the air like carbon fumes.
The earth was scorched,
the waterways dried up,
the white Egrets disappeared.
Creeping insects of all kinds
eked out their slithery existence,
leaving behind silver threads of
slime on the desiccated water bed.
Sylvia and Danny hid from the sun.
In the house, the air conditioner
cooled their parched bodies."
So, by the end of the story,
we've come to understand something
about both the mother and the son,
and perhaps, even to sympathize.
There's the picture of what
her second volume looked like.
And here she is near
the end of her life.
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb: Finally,
why did Blume Lempel write
in Yiddish, and keep
writing in Yiddish,
even as the Yiddish readership grew
smaller and smaller year by year?
She wrote, "Yiddish is in my bones.
I hear my mother's [Yiddish
word spoken] in my head,
and I lift my eyes to the heavens,
and hear God answering
me in Yiddish.
The birds, real and
imagined, speak Yiddish.
And the wind at my
window speaks Yiddish,
because I speak Yiddish,
think in Yiddish.
So Yiddish was a portable homeland.
A way of remaining true to
a world that was no more,
while she made her
way to new places,
confronting new circumstances,
in new languages.
Yiddish was also a way to honor
the six million who perished
in the Holocaust, including
the members of her own family.
She wrote, "My older brother
tells me what to write in Yiddish,
directing my stories
from beyond the grave.
This is how it was.
This is what happened.
So must it be recorded.
You did not survive simply to
eat blintzes with sour cream.
You survived to bring back
those who were annihilated.
You must speak in their
tongue, point their fingers."
And for Lempel, Yiddish
was also a way to hide.
Writing in Yiddish
could feel isolating.
But we think maybe that
very isolation freed Lempel
to pursue her own idiosyncratic
vision.
Even as she was being published
in Yiddish periodicals,
receiving literary prizes,
and corresponding in Yiddish
with readers and writers all over
the world, living in her sbibh.
At the same time, her children
couldn't read what she wrote,
and her neighbors in
Long Beach, New York,
had no idea she was a
world published writer.
She told Itzel Gottesman this.
"I hide my literary
existence under my apron.
If you ask my neighbors
about my writing,
they'd think you were crazy."
So perhaps writing in Yiddish in
an English-speaking world helped
to liberate Lempel to be the
taboo-defying writer she was meant
to be.
>> Ellen Cassedy: When Blume died
in 1999, at her home in Long Beach,
Long Island, an article in the
[inaudible], the Yiddish newspaper
in New York stated, "With
the passing of Blume Lempel,
Yiddish literature has lost one
of its most remarkable writers.
An empty spot has opened
in the galaxy
of talented women Yiddish writers."
So, in closing, we want to read
to you a luminous passage from one
of Lempel's most extraordinary
stories called Waiting
for the Ragman.
And it is about her girlhood in
the little town in Eastern Europe,
and about how her memories have come
with her, have traveled with her
into adulthood, and this time, I'm
going to read you the Yiddish first,
and see how much you can get.
[ Yiddish Being Spoken ]
>> Ellen Cassedy: And
now in English,
"The young Passover son liked
to play with the colored glasses
that stood on the sideboard
in honor of the holiday.
The son poured the colors
together and transmuted them
into shimmering stars that
spangled the whitewashed walls,
the clay floor, and the table
with its Seder plate set
in the middle of the snowy cloth.
As I lifted my hands in the air,
the beams rained down over my head,
like a golden raisin wine that
began to ferment inside me.
To this day, I capture
handfuls of sunbeams,
and use them to illuminate
the shadows."
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb: During
her lifetime, Lempel's dream
of an English language readership
for the most part eluded her.
It is a joy for us now to help
her unrealized dream come true.
As we bring Blume's shimmering
sunbeams, and her abundant shadows
to new readers like you, we hope
we're helping this great writer
to be known as she
wanted to be known,
as a bold explorer of new terrain.
As a dazzling stylist, and as
a profound teller of truths
about the human condition.
As new generations of readers
encounter Lempel's work,
whether in the original
Yiddish, or in translation,
they will have the opportunity
to step into her sbibh.
As they do, they'll
be richly rewarded.
We hope you'll enjoy her
work, savor it, learn from it,
and share it with others.
So, again, thank you all for
coming, and [Yiddish being spoken].
[ Applause ]
>> Ellen Cassedy: So questions
are welcome, and as Sharon told us
at the beginning, just be aware
that if you do ask a question,
your image will appear on
the podcast that is sent
out by the Library of Congress.
Yes sir?
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Ellen Cassedy: So the question
is whether there were any outside
influences on this writer, outside
the Yiddish literary circle.
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb: Go ahead.
>> Ellen Cassedy: She always
said that she wasn't influenced
by anybody, that she was not
part of any literary school,
and that she pursued her
own path and didn't borrow
from anyone, as she put it.
On the other hand, I feel that she,
having come from this tiny town,
by the banks of a river that had no
name, became a Western intellectual.
And she was familiar with,
for example, Oedipus.
That is part of our
Western literary legacy.
She knew about Freud.
That is very evident in the story.
The Oedipus in Brooklyn,
and she read widely.
She, according to her children,
had a lot of books in the house.
So somehow, something seeped in,
but it is not possible to say, oh,
she is kind of like so-and-so.
I tried to develop a theory
that she is like a blend
of the writer Grace Paley, who
is this kind of wise-cracking,
down to earth, Brooklyn New
York voice, Bronx voice.
Grace Paley, and Gabrielle
Garcia-Marquez,
surreal butterflies,
sunbeams, and so on.
So you could sort of see that.
But I don't think she read
either of those writers.
So maybe she picked it up
through her pores, I don't know.
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb: She
also mentions in passing Spinoza,
and the French philosopher
Henri Bergson.
Again, just in passing.
She doesn't really cite
them as major influences.
But other people have, you
know, said well this knowledge,
this skill must have
come from somewhere.
I mean, the thing about
what we know is based a lot
on this video interview
that we have.
And it is a moment in time.
So maybe if someone asked her that
question like five years later,
there might have been
a different answer.
It is not like today where
people leave a lot more traces
of themselves, in terms
of responses to things,
like the question of
literary influence.
So yeah.
>> Ellen Cassedy: Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb:
So the question was,
did she have any interaction with
Basheva Singer [phonetic spelling].
And the questioner thought
that there was some
magical realism in Singer.
None that we know of.
Not as far as I know.
She may have read him.
But I don't know of any
personal contact with him.
At other sessions, someone asked
about Chaim Grade, specifically,
we mention because that person
thought that some of the passages
that we were reading
could have come from Grade
in terms of the poeticism.
And while we both, while Grade was
a master of both poetry and prose,
the particular way that Blume
Lempel brought it all together is
uniquely hers.
I mean, I read extensively
in Grade, and I did not,
I've never encountered
anything like this in Grade.
>> Ellen Cassedy: Someone
also at one
of our lectures mentioned
Marc Chagall, the artist,
and said there is something
there about, you know,
cows flying over the house and
so on, and I think that's true.
But I think it comes from a culture,
rather than from actual
contact between these writers.
There was contact between writers,
and they definitely
sustained each other,
but I don't see a literary influence
so much as just the support for,
go for it, say what you want to say.
Did somebody else have a question?
Yes, you.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Ellen Cassedy: So the questioner
said that we did a lot of research
on her, and did we find any traces
of the early work that she burned?
And is there a Bibliography
about her?
We didn't find traces, no.
We do know that the
typewriter that she typed on,
thank goodness she typed, because
her handwriting is pretty fearsome,
that typewriter was given
to her by the editor of one
of the Yiddish newspapers in New
York early on, and she continued
to use it for the rest of her
life, and we did find some stories
that we couldn't track
down in any publications.
We looked through here at
the Library of Congress,
we looked through bound volumes
of Yiddish literary journals,
and we did find some stories
that are not in her collections,
but I don't think that
those burned works survived.
But it was quite fascinating.
We had lots of, she had lots of
correspondence with writers all
over the world, sort of like a
virtual caf, where in the old world
in Warsaw, they might
have been sitting
around all day drinking
their tea and talking,
here they were writing
letters to each other,
and we have those letters.
So that was quite fascinating.
As for a bibliography, we have
written an essay about her
that exists in a collection
of Yiddish women writers.
And we have not put it together, but
there are, we know of some reviews
of her, everything in Yiddish.
So yeah.
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb: Yeah.
Joan?
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb: So the
question was about the challenges
of translation given
her unique style.
And there were many.
The challenge is how you are
going to represent, you know,
a writer who moves back and
forth in time, intense in places,
sometimes within the same sentence.
Sometimes in the same
paragraph, the same page.
Is she talking about now?
Is she talking about
the distant past?
The not so distant past?
All those questions came into play.
It was really good to have
someone to bounce ideas off of
and to check, is this what you got?
Did I get this?
So we did a lot of back and forth.
We should also just say like
a word about our process.
We each read all the stories
and then wrote our own kind
of synoptic reviews, recommendations
for inclusion or exclusion,
and then came up with our short
list and then went back and forth
and came up with these stories,
and then in terms of the drafts,
we split up, who would do the
first draft, which stories,
and we did first drafts, then sent
it to the other person for critiques
and lots of red ink and tears, etc.,
etc. But it was all good in the end.
>> Ellen Cassedy: Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Ellen Cassedy: How did
we select the stories?
There are...there are another, I
don't know, maybe 30 or 40 stories
that are out there that we read and
decided not to put in this volume.
We pick the best [laughter], the
good ones, the really good ones.
Yeah, I mean, sometimes it was
hard because even these stories,
you're sort of going along
a particular narrative path,
and all of a sudden there is this
[makes sound effect] total 180
degree turn and you're going off
in a completely other direction,
and we're thinking, are we going
to be able to keep up with this?
Are we going to be able to convey
the power of this work even
with these crazy jagged
twists and turns?
But in the end, we
feel very satisfied
with what we've put together,
and it covers, as her work does,
it goes from the old world to the
new world, there is Paris in there,
there is New York, there
is the women's movement,
there is Florida, there
is South Carolina.
So there is really a very eclectic
group of settings, but it all,
the themes kind of,
as you go through,
it is a very satisfying kind
of read, because things build
on each other, and the layers, those
layers go inside you as a reader,
and you bring that to the
table in each successive story.
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb: I
just want to add to that.
I mean, the question of
selection is always a challenge,
and some of it is, you know,
guided by the marketplace,
the book is already like
well over 200 pages,
and so we couldn't make it a
collected stories, so we did have
to make some tough decisions, and
you know, there might have been some
that we could have included
that, on second read, you know,
maybe could have made the
final cut, but you know,
in the end, we believe in these.
So yeah. There are
other gems out there
that are not in this
collection also.
>> Ellen Cassedy: Maybe
one last question?
Mm-hmm.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Ellen Cassedy: So the question
is, this is the first translation,
the collection of translated work,
stories, and is there any other work
out there in translation?
Yes, this is the first collection
of her translated stories.
Her novel that was serialized
in a Yiddish newspaper was
translated in 1954, I believe.
I don't know why whom.
But there is a copy of it here
at the Library of Congress,
we found it here, and you
can come in and read it.
It is called Storm Over
Paris, and it is the story
of a Jewish woman living in
Paris during World War II,
who has an affair with a Nazi.
Pretty wild.
It's a kind of very different
from these stories,
it is a realist novel.
Very plot-driven.
So there is that.
And that is, as we said, there is a
story here and there that appeared
in journals over the years,
but nothing all put together.
So we are working very hard to
get this work out into the world.
It is being bought by libraries.
We are speaking at the Association
of Jewish Libraries in June,
and our publishers are doing what
they can to get it out there,
and we are depending on
you to spread the word.
>> Yermiyahu Ahron Talb: And someone
has just told me that he took
out the book from the
Brooklyn Public Library,
the Kensington Branch, so it is
in the Brooklyn Public
Library [laughter],
which seems very appropriate.
>> Ellen Cassedy: And it is also
available on Amazon and Barnes
and Noble, and through
the publisher.
You can order it online.
>> Yermiyahu Ahron
Talb: And here today.
>> Ellen Cassedy: And
also in the book store
of the library of Congress.
And also at that table
right behind you.
We are happy to sign it.
Okay, so thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.